ce qui mettrait en péril l'existence de
plusieurs régions plusieurs quotidiens
en région et l'on parle par exemple le
droit le quotidien le soleil la voix de
l'est ce sont des quotidiens donc de
capital médian rien n'est confirmé mais
du côté du volant legault on a laissé
entendre que la porte était ouverte pour
une aide d'urgence selon la presse
quebecor et cogeco seraient intéressés à
en faire l'acquisition avec nous a
gentiment léveillé vice président de la
fpjq fédération professionnelle des
journalistes du québec
bonjour j'entame un jour là comment et
pour voir donc c'est difficultés
financières j'ai capté à média faut s'en
inquiéter comme commence a commencé en
inquiète depuis depuis des années parce
que imaginer en fait on peut pas
imaginer la disparition des quotidiens
régionaux au québec des quotidiens qui
dans bien des cas sont le seul journal
dans leur milieu
c'est pas galvauder vous savez quand on
dit que les médias sont essentielles à
la démocratie pensez vous que quentin mr
magoo yeux autorise le remblai john
humide ou quand il passe sous silence de
la contamination d'eau potable dans une
municipalité pensez vous qu'ils
n'envoient communiquer un message une
lettre à ses citoyens évidemment que non
ça prend des médias ça prend des
journalistes pour fouiller poser des
questions assurer un certain
contre-pouvoirs et sa baisse et le rôle
de ces médias là ils sont pas les seuls
mais sont de plus en plus seul
particulièrement dans les régions et
particulièrement dans les petits milieux
ans extrêmement inquiétant donc
assurément ça voudrait dire des pertes
d'emplois mais vous ce qui vous inquiète
davantage pour l'instant en tout cas
c'est de voir la vitalité de
l'information qui serait en péril
évidemment que ça veut dire des pertes
d'emplois et saucier s'est désolé m et
des pertes d'emploi vous savez dans le
milieu des médias on est habitués on
entend plus souvent des annonces de
licenciements des annonces d'embauchés
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est près
de la moitié des journalistes au pays en
moins qu'on a
non c'est énorme les médias au fait je
suis juste il faudrait revoir le chef du
gspc la moitié des journalistes où la
moitié des médias mais il ya une chute
énorme continuelle et ont des plans on
crie à l'aide depuis des années et
malheureusement on n'a pas l'impression
d'être entendu d'être pris au sérieux
il ya eu dernièrement notamment au
niveau fédéral certaines mesures d'âge
mais sa vie c'est comme si on est dans
une barque qui coule on écope donc on
remet de l'argent mais on colmate pas la
brèche
la solution l épaule à la solution c'est
de permettre aux médias d'évoluer dans
un environnement fiscal compétitif et ça
les gouvernements pour l'instant nous ne
le font pas on a espoir que la
commission parlementaire dans une
dizaine de jours à québec va permettre
de trouver des solutions mais pour
l'instant on n'en a pas ou f1 ou donc
cette commission parlementaire pendant
laquelle on va parler également des
causes aussi là l'origine de tout ça
c'est bien sûr le transfert des
publicités qui se trouve maintenant sur
les géants du web
donc vraiment le modèle d'affaires des
médias est écroulé oui mais on entend
souvent dire que si le modèle d'affaires
des médias fonctionnerait il serait pas
dans le trouble c'est pas tout à fait
vrai il faut rectifier les choses de le
modèle d'affaires fonctionne parce que
la publicité elle existe encore elle
s'est déplacée sur internet sur les
géants du web comme facebook twitter
donc le modèle d'affaires il fonctionne
et d'ailleurs il n'ya pas un problème de
lecteurs non plus parce que le lectorat
des journaux ce métier les gens lisent
les journaux les gens aiment les
journaux les gens s'informent dans les
journaux ça ça se maintient
le problème c'est que les géants du web
prennent le contenu des journaux le
diffuse engrangent des revenus
publicitaires là dessus et les journaux
eux ne reçoivent rien autrement dit les
journaux payent des salaires de
journalistes tout plein de dépenses mais
non plus les revenus liés à ça c'est
comme si vous aviez un restaurant que
moi j'étais une compagnie de livraison
que je livrais vos repas des clients
mais que je gardais tous les revenus
qu'est ce que vous diriez vous dirais
que c'est du vol c'est ça c'est du jeune
et résultant pour la démocratie locale
orvoine
est ce qu'il ya une baisse du nombre de
médias dans les régions seulement les
gens ont des difficultés à s'impliquer
politiquement ce volet là parce que
plusieurs études ont démontré notamment
que l'application citoyenne
l'implication politique des gens est
plus forte quand ils sont bien informés
donc forcément quand ils ont plusieurs
médias ou s'abreuver mais mais mais je
reviens ce que je disais aussi au début
dans quand il n'y a pas de médias quand
il n'ya pas notamment de journaux dans
un milieu mais on est un peu plongé dans
le noir
et là ça laisse place à toutes les
magouilles possibles et inimaginables
parce qu'on a le temps d'attendre le
rapport de la commission parlementaire
sur la crise des médias il faut agir
dans le cas de capital médias je ne le
sais pas je suis pas au courant des
chiffres je ne sais pas plus que vous
mais peut-être peut-être que non et
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et il ne
faut pas laisser disparaître davantage
de journaux qu'on en a laissé
disparaître jusqu'à aujourd'hui ce
serait une catastrophe
jean-thomas léveillé vice président de
la fpjq merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci